Kristen is with us in Los Angeles hi
Kristen welcome to Dave Ramsey show hi
there I've been watching your show a lot
for the past couple years so I'm really
happy to be on here
well thanks art gonna help well I do
have mistakes that I have made
throughout my college years and I ended
up with $100,000 in debt and
unfortunately I've had 20,000 of it go
to collections the past four years ago
and after two years they graced it and
they forgave it but my student loans
have still gone to that eighty four
thousand dollars with those interest and
right now I'm trying to work on my
mental health and I'm trying to balance
what I should prioritize because I do
work full-time at my job my medical
deductible is 1800s and that looks about
a hundred and eight dollars a month that
I'm paying to help my mental health but
that's coming out of my bill the money
that I would pay for my student loans
okay what is wrong with your mental
health well I've lived most of my life
with depression and atvs and lately with
the past year and everything that has
gone on I've had to prioritize it as a
necessity and it has helped but it is
something that's going to be constant
every month checking in with
psychiatrist counselors and having to
pay those bills in order to maintain it
and so my monthly expenses I only get
like maybe three hundred four hundred a
month and I can usually afford if I'm
really being short on my money and my
student loans they're expecting me to
pay upwards to two hundred and fifty
months total and so that's usually the
least amount of money that I have so I'm
trying to pick and choose what's the
best option don't you okay how old are
you 29 what do you do I'm a photographer
actually and I really love my job and
what's your degree in I have a BFA in
film Media Studies oh good okay so
you're a photographer video or still my
degree is
particularly in law what do you do for a
living oh I take pictures at the
Disneyland Resort oh okay cool so how
many hours a week are you working at
that full-time that can usually range
from 38 hours to 48 on a very busy weeks
okay and and what is your income in a
year I proximate it at 35 okay well we
have as you can imagine folks that
struggle with depression or or a DD in
an extreme level or ADHD often have
financial issues bipolar in particular
okay and so I've had the experience of
working with folks dealing with that for
many years decades I don't I'm not a
mental health professional I don't know
anything except just experience of
watching this and dealing with it the
good news is is that I've seen a lot of
people deal with it and actually put it
in their past work past it or work it
down to where it is such a minor issue
that it no longer runs their life they
run it and that's an the process of what
you're doing trying to get on top of
this and I commend you for that well
done there is no what I'm telling you is
there's a lot of hope the other thing
I've seen is there's two sides to the
money equation that affect both of those
things one is the cause and the effect
okay meaning that sometimes depression
obviously causes energy to drop a hope
to drop and so there's a there's there's
initiative goes out the window sometimes
and so people don't work much you know
that are depressed yeah and so that
causes the income to go down and causes
the money to have a problem and then
guess what it spirals because when you
got financial stress guess what that's
depressing right exactly
okay so that's kind of one side of the
equation the other side of the equation
is I have actually seen a sizable
increase in income be part of the fight
to win against depress
not that money makes you happy that's
not the point but the lack of stress
around life as related to money makes it
easier to fight depression is that
logical absolutely and so my
recommendation not as a mental health
professional but just as a guy who's
walked with folks like you that are
facing the kinds of things you're facing
all these years is let's do something
really really let's go crazy on the
income side what can you do with that
camera and double your income in your
off hours I want you to go bananas kiddo
I have a feeling you are way underpaid
for the level of talent you have looking
through that lens you've not only been
formally trained you have a passion for
it you have an enjoyment with it and I
think you're probably better than
$35,000 a year thank you see you I think
so prove it I definitely can yeah my
butt off and doing that yeah let's take
sighs yes you're you're you're freakin
in Los Angeles
let's take side gigs let's take pictures
of dogs I don't care what you're doing
but let's go turn that camera into money
and see how exciting it would be to make
$70,000 and then we're not pinching
pennies and worrying about choosing
between my counselors bill and my
student loan bill because a $500 a month
income that's only six thousand dollars
a year changes the entire question you
just asked me doesn't it yes yes it does
and you're only working 38 to 48 lots of
people work eight lots of people work 80
I don't want you to work 80 the rest of
your life but how cool would it be to
make an extra forty thousand for the
next two years and almost completely
alleviate the student loan debt and
maybe in the process find legs to what
God wants you to do with that camera
yeah very true I'm gonna send you a copy
of Christie Wright's book business
boutique because
not sure what your side hustle is but it
might be some kind of a thing where
you're doing it on a self-employed basis
running your own business
I really think you're getting ready this
is this this is real pivotal time for
you all that all that you've done has
brought you to this point and this
stress may birth something really cool
it may force you to go out of your
comfort zone and go use that camera make
some money unapologetically make some
money $10,000 in your hand extra would
change your whole outlook only $10,000
you can do this